ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Hello Welcome.
The good news, we're
basically done.
We've covered all of the theory.
The only thing
we're going to do,
the remaining part
of the course,
is to think through several
applications of Fourier.
Today I'll do some just really
easy motivational things.
I'll do another
example from filtering,
just because that's
such an important idea.
I'll talk about how Fourier
transforms show up in physics.
And then, starting
next week, we'll
talk about sampling, which
is just a simple application
of Fourier.
You've already sort of seen
it in the last lecture.
And then we'll talk about
modulation, which is yet
another application of Fourier.
So basically you
have the theory,
and all we're going to do for
the remainder of the course
is think about
applications of Fourier.
So we already talked
about a filter.
I motivated a filter by
thinking about Fourier series
because it's easy.
If you think about
the system that's
comprised of a resistor
and a capacitor,
and you have as an input
vi and an output vo,
then you can think about
that system being a filter.
The filter can be characterized
by a frequency response.
You're all experts at that.
And then if you can break the
signal into Fourier components,
which was easy when we
had a Fourier series,
if you can break the signal
into Fourier components
then it's easy to calculate the
output as the sum of weighted
and possibly time
shifted versions
of the components of the input.
So we can decompose the
signal, the square wave,
into a bunch of
Fourier components.
And then think about how
they pass through the filter.
Where if they all pass
through the low frequency
part of the filter, so that the
gain is one and the phase is 0,
the output looks
just like the input.
And if they all pass through
the part of the filter that's
sloping down with
a slope of minus 1,
with the phase
lagging by pi over 2,
you turn a square wave
into a triangle wave.
That was the simplest
example of a filter.
We saw it again when we thought
about speech production.
Because there the idea was that
the different kinds of sounds
that we make are partially
generated by the larynx,
and partially generated
by the throat.
And it's all the
musculature in your face
that enables you to make the
precise different sounds.
And that was what we
called the source filter
model of speech production.
The sources down here,
the filter is here.
And we again, we can think about
it by thinking about filtering.
Filtering comes up
all over the place,
and it's one of the most
important applications
of Fourier techniques generally.
And it's for all the
reasons you already know.
If you can think of a
way of breaking down
a signal into
Fourier components,
then you can thing about
an LTI system as a filter.
And in filtering applications,
in signal processing filtering
applications, we
usually try to think
about high frequencies,
low frequencies,
designing systems
that pass the lows,
pass the highs,
that sort of thing.
But the key is
breaking down an input,
which might be
complicated in the pieces.
That's where the Fourier
transform is so good.
And so, I want to
illustrate that
by thinking about a hard
problem in signal processing,
and that is an
electrocardiogram.
So first off, it's
completely amazing
that you can measure an
electrocardiogram at all.
The voltages
produced by cells are
on the order of 100 millivolts.
That's true for all cells for
extremely fundamental reasons,
which if you're interested in,
6021 has a lot of information
about why.
There are fundamental
physical limits
on what kinds of a
voltage a cell can make.
So the voltages are small, but
they're much worse than that,
they're constrained to
the inside of a cell.
You can't generally get access
to the inside of a cell.
In fact, there's a big
technological breakthrough,
and people figured
out how to draw--
cells are little.
It's kind of hard to
imagine how little they are.
About two to three million
cells would fit in the length,
in a one inch length
of a human hair.
And that's a skinny
hair like mine.
So blonde skinny hair.
The rest is not necessarily
skinny, but they're skinny.
So you can get about
a million cells,
maybe two million cells in
one length, one inch of--
length of a human hair.
To give you some idea
of how small they are.
These tiny, tiny,
tiny little things.
So it was a big deal
when people were
able to measure inside a cell.
And when you put
electrodes on your chest
to measure an electrocardiogram,
you're not inside a cell.
Cells are surrounded
by an insulator.
So not much of that electrical
current is available to you.
Furthermore, the cells in the
heart are surrounded by saline.
What's important about saline?
What is saline?
Salt water.
What's important about saline?
What would be
different if we were
filled with distilled water?
Besides the fact
that we would die.
Yeah.
Conducts electricity.
So the fluid that
bathes the cells
has a very high
ionic concentration.
And that means that it
conducts electricity,
which means most
of the potentials
are shorted out before they ever
get to the surface of the skin.
Then there's another 20
layers of insulation,
called your skin.
So it's astonishing that you
can even measure these things.
And when you do,
it's not surprising
that there's a lot of
signal in the waveform,
other than the signal
that you intend.
There's about 10 to the
13th neurons in your body,
and they're all chattering away.
So you see those.
So that the idea of filtering
out the part of the signal
that results from the EKG
is completely non-trivial.
And it's very useful to think
about it in a Fourier domain.
And absolutely everybody
does it that way.
If you were to take the Fourier
transform of this waveform,
you would get a
wave form that looks
like this, which looks
perhaps more complicated.
except that you can make
some sense out of it.
Hearts beat about 60
or 70 times a minute,
depending on how athletic
and how old you are,
which means that it's
the components around 1
or bigger that are
coming from the heart.
Things significantly
lower than hertz
probably aren't
coming from the heart.
Things that are up in the
10 kilohertz region probably
are not from the heart.
This enormous
spike, what's that?
That's the lights.
That's the power.
That's the-- we distribute
electrical power by modulating
it at 60 hertz because
that distributes better,
but then it radiates.
And so some of that can be
coupled into everything,
including me.
So the big line is
the 60 hertz that's
being coupled from the
power distribution network
into the person
whose EKG this is.
So what we'd like to
do then is generate
a filter that takes out
the stuff that isn't EKG.
So we'd like to eliminate
this low frequency stuff,
and we'd like to eliminate this
high frequency stuff, right?
So what we do is
we design a filter.
Filter design Bode of course.
Right?
Smile?
Everybody smile, you know?
There's nothing on a quiz
for weeks to come, right?
So Bode.
So we would think about
passing the high frequencies.
I didn't say that right.
So we would like to
cut off the very lows,
we'd like to cut
off the very highs.
And we'd like to get rid of
that one glitch at 60 hertz.
So the 60 hertz thing, that's
what this is intended to do.
It's intended to be a
very narrow filter that
just wipes out the 60.
So this is a kind of filter
that I'd like to design.
And here is the design.
Handful of poles and 0s.
Your task, talk to your neighbor
and figure out which poles
and which 0s go with the
high pass, the low pass,
and the notch.
Look at your neighbor,
say hi, smile.
OK, so which of the poles and
0s contribute to the high pass?
Rught, you can point.
Like, there's up, and there's
left, and there's center.
So which ones are high pass?
The ones near 0.
The 0 or the poles?
Or one of each,
or both, or what?
So what would the Bode plot
look like if you only had the 0?
Yeah.
So the 0 alone would cancel
out frequency components at 0.
Which our Bode plot is
a way over there, right?
What about these poles?
What's the poles for?
They flatten that it out.
So if you think
about reading off
the effect of the poles
and 0s starting at 0
and going to bigger
and bigger radiuses,
then the first thing
you have to worry
about going left to
right on the Bode plot,
is the 0s doing this.
And then these poles
flatten out the 0s.
So what's this doing?
That's the thing
that's attenuating
the high frequencies,
which leaves us with this.
What's that?
And how do you
know it's a notch?
There's a 0.
So the 0 on the
j-omega axis means
there's a frequency that
it completely wipes out.
Why do I need to have
this stupid pole here?
Can't I just put the 0 there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Bring it back up.
So the idea is that if you
put the pole close to the 0,
if you get to a frequency that's
pretty far away from those,
their effects
cancel, and there's
no effect of either of them.
So their effect is
constrained to frequencies
that are very close measured
in terms of this distance.
So you have to be at a frequency
that's very close in order
to have an effect.
And when you do that, when
you design such a filter,
you clean up the
wave form a lot,
and no one in their right mind
would generate an EKG machine
that didn't do this.
I mean, that's just built
into the preamplifier that's
attached to the electrodes.
So the point is that filtering
is very important application
of Fourier transforms.
We can take an arbitrary signal
and often get a lot of insight
into what we would like to
preserve and remove by thinking
about the Fourier
transform, insights
that you wouldn't get by
looking at the time wave form.
Next thing I want to think
about is a little bit different.
I want to think about physics.
This isn't, of course, in
physics, nor am I a physicist,
but I do do optics.
And the thing I want to
think about is diffraction.
You can't understand
optics unless you
think about diffraction,
and honestly the easiest way
to think about diffraction
is Fourier transform.
So a very simple
example of diffraction.
So here is a
diffraction grating.
So if I pass a coherent beam
through there, which I just
happen to have, if I
pass a coherent beam
through a diffraction
grating, what do you see?
The diffraction
grating split one beam.
All term I've been
pointing with one.
Well, if I put this in front
of it, now I get three.
So somehow there's
something about this that's
breaking one beam into three.
Can you think why?
Can you remember 802 where
they probably mentioned this?
What is this?
What's in here?
AUDIENCE: Slits.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Slits.
Close.
Yeah.
So the simplest
experiment where you
could illustrate this kind of
a diffraction phenomenon is--
goes by the name--
yes.
Shout the name.
Young.
AUDIENCE: Double
slit experiment.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Double
So if you pass light
through two slits,
something phenomenal happens.
And it's very closely
related to this.
What's in this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Something like a slit.
It's actually something
like a whole bunch of slits.
So, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Polarizer.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Polarizer.
Close.
It's one of those neat words
from physics, but not quite.
Polarized has to
do with the fact
that the light has an
e field and an m field,
and they are perpendicular
to each other,
and sources like this one
actually keep them separate.
So this actually does
generate polarized light,
but you can't really tell
because if I spin the laser
pointer, you can't
really see anything.
But if I spin the grating--
I just said something.
So what did I just call this?
AUDIENCE: Grating.
DENNIS FREEMAN: Grating.
So what is it?
It's a diffraction grating.
It's got a bunch of little
horizontal structure.
So the idea is here.
The grating, you can think
about it as an array,
big array, big
compared to the size
of the point that
I was eliminating,
big array of scatterers.
So you think about
having a material that
transmits light
and a material that
scatters light and a material
that scatters light is arranged
in lines.
And the lines are separated
from each other by some kind
of a distance, here
represented by a capital D.
And the reason that you
see the far-field pattern,
we call that the far-field
pattern as opposed
to the near-field pattern.
If I were to do this
and put it very close,
then I would think
about the pattern being
the near-field pattern if
I get close compared to D.
So if the slits are D apart,
the near-field is D close,
and the far field is when
I'm far away compared to D.
So if I'm far away
compared to D,
then you can imagine that the
light is coming in this way,
and each one of these
generates scatter.
So there is a spherical
wave coming way out
from each of these.
That's Huygens' principle.
Right
So the idea then is that
there are contributions
from each one of
these scatterers
out here in the far field.
Each point in the
far field picks up
a little bit of light from
each of the scatterers,
but they're in different
phase relationships.
They were in phase when the
coherent light struck these.
But now if I were to
think about a point here,
the phase that you get is
different from the point here.
So here the phase from two
points would be about the same.
Here they would be different
because the distance traveled
from this scatterer
is that much longer.
So if I look at a
particular angle,
then each of these scatterers is
a different optical path length
from the source.
That means that if I arrange the
angle so that this is lambda,
the light that
scatters off of here
will constructively
interfere with the light that
scatters off of here and here.
Everybody see that?
So that means that there's a
funny angle, the sign of which
is lambda over D in which you
get constructive interference,
and that's what's going on
with the diffraction grating.
And you can see that.
There are several illustrations
of that all over the place.
Here I have a CD and a DVD.
Which one is which?
I'm showing you the
backside of a CD and a DVD.
AUDIENCE: DVD is
in the left side.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
DVDs is this one.
How do you know that?
AUDIENCE: Because it looks blue.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
Because it looks blue.
Why does it look blue?
Not a clue.
It's just they always do.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: Smaller.
So somehow this one reflects
better, the bluer lights,
so you see more of
that, and this one
reflects better longer lights.
This one has got a
greenish twinge maybe.
Kind of like all colors.
I like to call it green.
Maybe it's because
I know the answer.
So if I take these guys, I can
get the same sort of thing,
so I'll take the CD first.
Now, of course, this
has a coding on it,
so if I try to shine a
laser straight through it,
not much will happen.
I don't really want
to blind somebody.
So I'm going to
take this and I'm
going to attempt to hit this
while watching back here,
which for somebody my age
it's pretty hard to do.
But the idea is going to be
that instead of using this
as a transmission grating, I'm
going to use it as a reflection
grating.
So if I do this--
so that's kind of cute.
So my laser is green.
What's lambda?
AUDIENCE: 530.
DENNIS FREEMAN: 530.
So let's round off.
Let's say 500.
Yes.
So I've got a green
laser, and what
will happen if I move
the laser back and forth?
How will the pattern change?
It won't change.
So if I do this, which I can't
do while I'm watching it,
no change.
What will happen if I
move this way this way?
Well, the angle is what matters.
So as I move it farther away,
the pattern gets bigger.
So if I do this, if I were at
all coordinated, which I'm not,
I'm trusting that
it's doing what
I'm telling it to because I
can't look at the same time.
So let me put this at a
precise 1 meter away, 3 feet.
And let me shine this
in here, and let me
do a very precise measurement.
And those are now one-foot
apart by my precise measurement
skills.
So what I'd like you to do
is figure out the pitch.
The information on a CD
is written will spirally.
That's the reason there
is an apparent color.
I just measured the pitch.
How far apart are the tracks?
So take the data.
So if I'm three feet
away from the screen,
the dots are
separated by one foot
and figure out how closely
spaced the tracks are on a CD.
So what's the answer?
1, 2, 3, 4.
None of the above.
A very small number of
votes, but about 90% correct.
So what do I do?
How do I figure it out?
Yeah.
So we just made a
big deal out of how
the distance, which
was D sine theta
had to be an integer
multiple of lambda.
So all we need to do is
think through some trig.
So if I think about
the dots being
a foot apart when I'm three feet
away, then the tangent is 1/3.
So the small angle
approximation is about 1/3,
so the sine is about 1/3.
So lambda is about 500
nanometers divided by 1/3.
And if I carry that out a little
more precisely, I get 1,613,
and the manufacturer's
specification for CDs
is 1,600 nanometers.
So it's 1.6 micrometers.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [? What ?] is the
precision on [INAUDIBLE]??
DENNIS FREEMAN: Oh,
they're pretty good.
In fact, we'll talk about
this a little later.
They do this by an
embossing process.
So you make a master
out of aluminum,
and then you stamp it.
And the stamping is
actually very good.
So probably the biggest
manufacturing problem
is the thermals.
So you stamp it in heated
polystyrene, so there's
a little bit of a coefficient
of shrinkage as it cools,
but it's not very big.
It's fractions of a percent.
So what will happen then
if I switch to the DVD,
how many tracks are on a DVD?
So we can do the same
kind of an experiment.
Now if I try to do
the DVD, in order
to get them to be a foot apart,
I have to get much closer.
So now to get D space at about a
foot, I have to be about a foot
away.
So what's the spacing on
the DVD, smaller or bigger?
So it's smaller because
the angle got bigger.
So it's the same sort of deal.
If you think about the one foot,
so you get one-foot spacing
with about one foot.
So then the tangent is about 1.
It's not quite a
small angle anymore.
So theta is 0.78.
And so the experimental value
comes out about 704 nanometers,
so it's about a factor of 2.
Smaller.
So we got about
700 nano, so it's
a fraction of a micron,
rather than 1.6 microns,
and that's why they
look a little different.
So we get about a factor of 2
in terms of information density
in terms of track count.
Of course, the information
is also stored more closely
within a track as well.
So instead of being about
a factor of 2 better,
it's maybe a factor of 4
better because the track
is based about a factor of 2.
You can do more
interesting things.
That's kind of the
most degenerate case
because that's one D.
So here is a fancier
grating from my lab, which has
the property that if I shine
the light through
it, I get more dots.
So what's inside this?
AUDIENCE: A 2D grating.
DENNIS FREEMAN:
It's a 2D grating.
So instead of having just
lines going this way,
it has lines going this way
and lines going that way.
And in fact, back about
5 or 10 years ago,
when laser pointers
were a novelty,
they became all the
rage to put them
right into your laser pointer.
So here's another laser pointer.
So here is a thing
that you screw
in the end, which has a fraction
grating built right into it.
And so now if I mean to say
some graphics reading off
the cursor, so there is a
cursor now in my laser pointer
rather than being a dot.
Or if I'm more chintzy,
now I can circle things.
I'm not sure why I want to do
that, but in case I wanted to,
I can do it.
If I wanted to underline
things, I guess.
I'm not sure.
The point is that these things
are just a diffraction grating.
All that's in there is a little
piece of glass that's got--
it's not actually glass.
It's actually plastic that was
made with an embossing process,
same as they make CDs with.
So if you're into--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: Yeah.
Who knows.
And if you go backwards in
time, they get even chintzier.
So this is an even
older laser pointer.
They're fun.
You can tell it's older because
it's red and it's dimmer.
If you think the click
art is kind of still--
this is my favorite.
Save the favorite for the end.
Dark side.
I don't know.
Anyway, so that's
kind of the idea.
The way you can think
about diffraction grating,
so now I want think about
a more general theory.
I've worked out
a specific theory
for a one-dimensional
diffraction grating,
now I want to think
about the general theory.
What if I simply told you
some pattern in space?
What if I told you your job is
to make the diffraction grating
to project a dollar sign.
How would you do it?
Take a wild guess.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: Take the
Fourier transform, of course.
So the idea.
So what would happen if the
target is more complicated
than a grating, the
way to think about this
is the think about just like
in the case of the grating,
if you collect the light
that hits the far field,
the far field bit has a
point in the far field,
came from all over the target
just like in the grating.
In the grating, the
point in the far field
came from every one
of the lines and there
was a simple relationship
among the phases that
came from each of
the lines, and that's
what gave rise to the
pattern in the far field.
Well, the same thing
is always true.
All the points in the image
in the far field came from--
each point, had contributions
from every point in the target.
And if you think about
points in the target,
now I'm going to think
about just one point
so this is the target space.
Way out there is the far field.
So in the target space,
there's an x-coordinate,
there's a y-coordinate,
there's a z-coordinate.
Let me just worry
about x for the moment.
This point that is x
displaced in this direction
contributes a different
phase to the far field
than a point that's at 0.
Because the point is at x,
you get a different phase.
And that phase relationship
depends, not just
on x, but also on the angle.
And this is the relationship,
the phase generated
by a scatterer at the point, x.
Just like the
one-dimensional grating,
if you take x and
multiply by the sine,
that tells you the
delay in meters,
but then you can convert
that into radians
by dividing by the wavelength
and multiplying by 2 pi.
So the phase that is
generated by scattering
from this point
displaced a distance, x,
when measured in angle,
theta, in the far field,
looks like that.
That's supposed to be just
a simple reiteration of what
we just did.
Now the tricky part is
that all of the light that
hits a particular
point in the far field,
a point in the far field
is characterized as theta.
Where is my laser pointer?
So if you go to the
far field at a place,
theta, the total amount of light
that hits the point, theta,
is the sum, the integral, of
all the different scatterers.
So f is x represents
how much light gets
scattered as a function of x.
x is the target.
So this is integrating
over how much
light gets scattered at each
x, and at a particular x,
you get this phase delay.
So there's a coherent sum then.
So you add up all of
these complex numbers
by the integral.
Now imagine that the sine
of theta is about theta.
That was true all of the
examples I've done so far.
So here I'm what, 15 feet
away, and it's a foot,
so that's small
angle approximation.
So now let's replace
sine of theta with theta,
and let's think about this
number, 2 pi theta over lambda.
That's just frequency omega.
So I'm thinking about
now the far field,
which we had previously
called dependent on theta.
Theta is just omega.
So I've got a relationship now
between how much scattering
happens at each x in the target
and what does the picture
look like in the far field.
And that's a Fourier transform.
So there is an exact Fourier
transform relationship.
Well, exact is a little
bit of an approximation
because I'm using a small
angle approximation.
I'm ignoring a few things.
Not only am I making a
small angle approximation,
but I'm assuming that if
the light goes straight
and if the light goes up, they
have the same intensity when
they hit the board.
That's not quite true.
That's with Fraunhofer
approximation blah, blah, blah.
Fancy names for a bunch
of approximations.
The point is that if you make
reasonable approximations,
you get a Fourier
transform relationship
between the scattering in the
target and far field image.
So now we have a
very convenient way
of thinking about what
happened whenever I shot
my laser through this thing.
I get a bunch of spots in
the far field because--
everybody shout.
This is the aha.
So we've got an impulse train
in the Fourier transform, which
means that the thing that was
down here was an impulse train.
because we know that the Fourier
transform of an impulse train
is an impulse train.
So this is an impulse
train in space.
The scatterers represent
an impulse train.
So whenever I illuminate
it, I getting impulse train
in the free transform
because the Fourier
transfer on an impulse
train is an impulse train.
Well, that's pretty cool.
So you all know why an impulse
train is an impulse train.
So this two dimensional grating
then, the interesting thing
about that then
is that it must be
the case that the Fourier
transform of a 2D impulse train
is a 2D impulse train.
So I want to think just
a minute about that.
What will we mean by a
two-dimensional Fourier
transform.
So two-dimensional
Fourier transforms.
I want x j omega 1, j omega 2.
So it's a lot like
a 1D transform.
I am going to think about having
x except now there's two time
variables, time 1 and time 2.
And I'm going to
have to have two
of these funny
exponential things.
So I'm going to have
e to the minus j
omega 1 t1 plus
omega 2 t2 d t1 d t2.
It's almost like a 1D transform
except I have two d's now.
And the way to think
about that, probably
shouldn't distract
you with this.
That's the next slide.
So the way to think about
this is this separates.
e to the j sum is e to
the j1 plus e to the j2.
So I can write this more simply
as x of t1, t2 e to the minus j
omega 1 t1 d t1.
So then I can integrate that,
e to the minus j omega d t2.
This is the integral
over the t1 variable.
So if I think about doing
the transform in steps,
this is the integral
I might say--
so let's say that I had
my original 2D thing
was a square that I'd
like to characterize
as a t1 dependence
and a t2 dependence.
The way I think about
the 2D transform,
this thing says, for each
t2, treat t2 as a constant,
for each t2, that's
for each row.
Treat t2 as a constant and
just take the Fourier transform
of the t1 direction.
So what I do is I take the
Fourier transform of this,
and I put it here, but
when I've done that,
I've changed the t1 axis
into an omega 1 axis
because the result of
integrating over t1
throws away the t1, but
I'm left with an omega 1.
If I repeat that for
all the different lines,
I didn't really change
this axis, which was t2,
so it's still t2.
All I've done now
is taken a bunch
of integrals in the middle.
Now, if I take the outer
integral, what I need to do
is integrate over t2.
So if I integrate over t2, now
I want to integrate this way.
Now, I want to
integrate out the t2.
The t2 goes away.
So I take Fourier
transforms this way.
For each column in
this space, I generate
a new Fourier transform
over here, and I repeat.
That doesn't change this one.
This one is still omega 1.
But then when I take the
transform this way, I had a t2.
That turns it into an omega 2.
So I started with t1-t2 space,
take all the transforms row
wise, make a new array, take
all the transforms column wise,
make a new array, and I end
up with omega 1, omega 2.
So if I do that, what's the
two-dimensional transform?
What if I started
with a vertical line?
What if my spatial dependence
had a vertical line in it?
What would be the
two-dimensional transform
of a vertical line?
Well, the rule says
transform all the rows.
What's the transform?
What do I call that function?
Shout.
I'm deaf.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: So let's say
the line has a height of 1,
and the background
has a height of 0.
So as I read across here
it's, 0 0, 0, 1, 0, 0, 0.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS FREEMAN: Exponential.
Impulse.
Impulse in left.
So when I take the
transform, I get 1.
I get constant.
So I get a constant over here,
and then I take this one.
Same thing.
Same constant, same
constant, same constant.
I end up with a
constant over here.
So this started out
being delta of t1.
This is a constant everywhere.
So now if I take the
column-wise transforms,
what's the transform
of a constant?
It's an impulse.
Where should the impulse be?
0.
So I end up when I do the
omega 2, the t2 transforms.
I get a delta in omega 2.
So I have omega 1 here,
and I have omega 2 here.
So I end up with a delta
function like that.
Then I do it again,
and I get one here.
And then I do it again,
So I end up with a line.
So vertical line in t1-t2 space
turns into a horizontal line
in omega 1-omega 2 space.
Got it?
It's all very simple.
And if I do the same thing,
if I did a horizontal line,
it will come out vertical.
And if I do a diagonal
line, it will rotate 90.
Very cute.
Y'all got it?
So the idea then is that there's
a very natural generalization
from a 1D transform
to a 2D transform,
and that's kind of fun, but
it's also kind of important.
So now for the important part.
So this is a picture, a
diffraction photomicrograph
done by Rosalind Franklin
back about 50 years ago.
She had taken DNA.
I can't remember.
I think it was from Drosophila,
but I don't really remember.
She had purified DNA.
And at that time, lasers
were not this size.
Actually, she used x-rays.
She used a source of
coherent light from an x-ray,
so it's not even a
laser, it was x-rays.
She fired coherent
x-rays at DNA--
so she had just a
big glob of DNA--
and took this picture.
And it was pretty
and pretty confusing.
By the way, just so you
know, this is an artifact.
This is a hole in the
photographic film.
So the idea was coherent source
of x-rays, sample of DNA,
into a photographic emotion.
Develop it, you get this.
So it's very similar to the
diffraction grating experiment
that I did except that the
target was not a diffraction
grating, it was not a CD,
it was not a DVD, it was DNA
That cute thing
is that she showed
this to Watson and
Crick, who were
geniuses at so many
different levels it's absurd,
and especially Watson knew
all about Fourier transforms.
And so he saw that
and immediately
was able to interpret
it as telling him
something about the
three-dimensional structure
of DNA.
In particular, if you think
about our modern view of DNA,
you can make an association
between the structure
of the DNA and this picture.
So there's a
high-frequency band.
So if you imagine that
what you're seeing
is three bright points
from a diffraction pattern
like I showed
previously, this and this
represents a high frequency.
This represents DC.
So the distance between
DC and the high frequency
is telling you something
about the inverse distance
between base pairs.
The highest frequency
in the x-ray picture
is inversely related to the
distance between the base
pairs.
The fact that there is these
closer-spaced frequencies,
those are actually
lower frequencies
because they're closer to 0--
we're in the far field, so
we're in the frequency domain.
Big frequency, small frequency.
The fact that we're seeing these
smaller frequency things here
and there are periodic, that
means there some structure
at bigger spacing, which
Watson and Crick interpreted
as the pitch of
the double helix.
So the helix is twisting.
This is the modern
picture, and it
fits very nicely
with the picture
that Rosalind Franklin made.
And the angles, the fact
that there is an axis here,
the reason for going
through all this junk
was to motivate the
idea that there's
an angle transformation in a
two-dimensional transform too.
In fact, angles in space
get rotated 90 degrees
when they're in frequency.
So the angle between
these solid lines
tells you something
about the angle
that the helix makes as
it's wrapping around.
So you can easily make 003
model of this experiment,
and that's what this is.
Here all I've taken
is a trivial model.
I just made a wire
frame that had
base pairs arranged as
a rotating spiral, just
like a spiral staircase.
Then that was a
three-dimensional picture.
Then I just flattened
it, and then I
took the two-dimensional
Fourier transform and got that.
Got it?
So the idea was I made a trivial
model for what DNA should look
like according to a
modern conception,
took the two-dimensional
Fourier transform,
and what you can see there
is all of the features
that you see in Rosalind
Franklin's picture.
You can see the big band that
corresponds to the base pairs,
you can see the smaller bands
that correspond to the twist,
and you can see the
angle that corresponds
to the angle of
the double helix.
So the point then
is just that there's
a lot of physical phenomenon.
Besides the signal
processing things
which we're very interested
in, there's actually
a lot of physical
phenomenon that
also have intrinsic meaning
within a Fourier domain,
and optics is a very
important example of that.
See you later.
Have a good day.